in the continuing saga of all the
disgusting and immoral and corrupt
things that Republican Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell has done he has
now blocked election security bills and
he just so happens to be taking money
from voting machine lobbyists nice right
this is a separate story by the way from
the totally swamp filling financial
dealings of Mitch McConnell's wife
Elaine Chao and her conflicts of
interest that's gonna have to be a story
for another day
this is other swamp filling nonsense
from Mitch McConnell remember Russian
hackers successfully targeted voting
machines in 2016 voting systems in 2016
they're likely to do it again in 2020 uh
intelligence agencies agrees agree the
intelligence agencies of other countries
agree touchscreen voting machines have
no paper trail some have no paper trail
which makes it impossible to verify how
votes were counted if they were counted
who they were counted for and these
electronic voting machines can make it
impossible not only to find but even to
correct problems in many cases there are
ideas about how to stop this both
Democrats and Republicans have actually
proposed some of those ideas in
legislation every single bill that has
been proposed has been stonewalled by
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell and of course big surprise it
just so happens that the two biggest
voting machine companies have hired
lobbyists at the federal level who
recently have contributed to Mitch
McConnell's re-election campaign for
Senate in Kentucky just delightful right
the system we have the two companies I'm
talking about our ES and s and Dominion
voting systems between the two of them
those two companies supply 80% of the
country's voting machines they have very
significant lobbying operations
historically at the state level but
they've now hired federal lobbyists ES
NS hired lobbyists Peck Madigan Jones to
lobby the House and Senate they have
significantly funded this federal
lobbying spending Dominion voting
systems now owned by a hedge fund based
in New York City also star
at federal lobbying this year with
Brownstein Hyatt Farber and Shrek a
different lobbying firm many of the
lobbyists working for both of these
companies have donated to Mitch
McConnell's campaign and to Mitch
McConnell's joint fundraising committee
so listen can we prove that Mitch
McConnell is blocking election security
bills because of the donations from
voting machine lobbyists no that's not
the point and that's by design that's
how the system is designed even if there
isn't actual provable foul play here
this is a corrupt system that it is even
legal for voting machine companies that
tally election results to go and donate
money to elected officials who are
participating in those elections which
may be tallied by their voting machines
is a sickening but legal status quo in
the way things work in this country last
segment I said we have over
criminalization in the street crime
world in the United States we have under
criminalization and under prosecution
and under conviction and under
penalisation of white collar corporate
and political crime in the United States
Mitch McConnell is one of the most
insidious forces in American politics
today and he has been for years and very
successfully so for Republicans his role
in helping Republicans control the
courts including his amazingly
successful if you're a Republican
obstruction of Obama's Supreme Court
nominee Merrick garland extremely
successful from the point of view of
Republicans his continued involvement in
covering up the full truth in the Mullah
report as we saw from day one after the
bar letter was released and now standing
in the way
regularly of election security this guy
has got to go there are unfortunately no
serious challengers right now on the
basis of polling at taking him down in
Kentucky I know that there was at least
one declared candidate that candidate
from the polling I've seen is not
standing any chance at this point in
time this guy's got to go and as much as
we need to get rid of Trump Mitch
McConnell has become an extremely
effective I don't even know what to call
him
he's been an extremely effective
operative for some of the bigger
Republican successes over the last ten
years it's disgusting and most of it is
legal today's program is sponsored in
part by Blink asam / Pakman if you've
not already heard about blinka it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a David Pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n